where we left off in the last video I
think we were getting a reasonably good
appreciation for how huge the Sun is
especially relative to the earth and how
far the earth is away from the Sun that
most of these diagrams that we see when
we in science textbooks they don't give
justice in fact you know when I showed
it this this Sun over here that was
about five or six inches across I said
you would be just this little speck
about 40 feet and it wouldn't be this
distance would be about 40 feet to the
left or the right or would have a radius
its orbit would have a radius of about
40 feet so it'd be this you know you
wouldn't even notice it if you were
looking at this thing over here would be
this little speck orbiting at this huge
huge distance if you look at this Sun
over here this Sun over here if I were
to draw the whole Sun it looks like
would have a it looks like I would have
a diameter of about 20 inches so in this
situation in this situation this earth
right here this is drawn to scale this
earth would not be anywhere near this
close it would be it would be about
about 200 feet that way or about 60 or
70 meters 60 60 meters so you can
imagine if the Sun was this size sitting
on something like a football field this
little speck of an earth this little
thing right here would be sitting on the
would be sitting on the the other
40-yard line
60 meters away so Hugh you wouldn't even
notice it this is it you might notice
this from a distance but you wouldn't
even see this thing over here and the
other planets are even further well not
all of the other planets obviously you
have mercury you have mercury here I'll
just I think where most of us are
familiar with these but I'll just list
them here just in case that's mercury
this is Venus mercury is the smallest of
the planets where it's not debated
whether it's a planet Pluto is the
smallest but some people debate whether
it's really a planet or kind of just a
large solar body or a dwarf planet or
any of those types of things but then
you have Venus probably the closest in
size to the earth or it is the closest
in size to the earth and then you have
Mars and then you have Jupiter and just
to give a sense of once again how far
these things are if I were to go back to
the analogy of this being the size of
the Sun then Jupiter is five times
further than Earth so this would be this
if I were to actually do
the scale distance this would be 300
meters away 300 meters so if I had a
nice big maybe medicine balled size Sun
right over here maybe basketball size a
little bit bigger than a basketball this
looks on my screen then I would have I
would put this little this little thing
that's smaller than a ping pong ball I
would put this three football fields
away that's how far
Jupiter is and then Saturn is about
twice as far as that Saturn is about
nine times the distance let me let me
make it clear this is the earth is one
astronomical unit away from the Sun
roughly its distance changes it's not a
perfectly circular orbit Jupiter is
approximately a little bit five-plus
astronomical unit so a little bit more
than five times the distance of the Sun
to the earth and Saturn Saturn is
approximately nine astronomical units or
nine times the distance from the Sun to
the earth so once again this would be
nine football fields away or another way
to think about it it'd be essentially a
kilometer away if we had a kind of a
medicine ball sized Sun this little
smaller than a ping pong ball Saturn
would be a kilometer away then I just
want it really or iterate it because you
never kind of visualize it that way
because just for the sake of being able
to draw it on a page you see diagrams
you see diagrams that look like this and
they really don't give you a sense of
how small these act these planets are
relative to the Sun and especially
relative to their distance from the Sun
and then after Saturn you have you have
Uranus Uranus and then Neptune and then
and then Neptune and obviously these
guys are even further just to give you a
sense you know it's very easy to start
talking about galaxies and and and the
universe is and all of the or the
universe but but I really just want to
get you know already what we've talked
about we're talking about huge distances
huge scale you know we already talked
about that it would take a jet plane 17
years to travel from the earth to the
Sun multiply that by five about a
hundred years to go from Jupiter to the
Sun 200 years to go from Saturn to the
Sun
so you could have had you could have had
a Abraham Lincoln get into a jet plane
and he still wouldn't have gotten if he
left from Saturn he still would not have
gotten to the Sun so these are huge huge
distances but we're not done with the
solar system they're just to give a
sense of scale so this is so this right
here that's the Sun and you know each of
these plants are actually narrower than
these orbits so they just draw these
orbits here but you would actually even
see the actual planets here at this type
of a scale but this is one astronomical
unit right over here the distance from
the Sun to the earth then you have Mars
then you have the asteroid belt there
you have the asteroid belt asteroid belt
which also has some pretty big things in
it itself and he has these things that
are kind of considered almost dwarf
planets things like Ceres you could look
those type things up and then you have a
Jupiter out here and once again we said
it would take a hundred years or roughly
a hundred years for a jet plane to get
from Jupiter to get from Jupiter to the
Sun but even if you take this whole box
here which is a huge amount of distance
roughly about five astronomical units it
would take about 40 minutes for the four
for light to get from the Sun to Jupiter
so this is a huge huge distance but even
this huge distance we can put it into
this little box right over here this
little box right over here so this whole
box this whole box right over there can
be fit can be fit into this box and that
you need to do that in order to
appreciate the orbits of the outer
planets and so on this scale you would
you would and and Venus and Mercury and
Mars their orbits look pretty much you
can't even differentiate them from the
Sun there they look so close they almost
look like they're part of the Sun when
you look at it on this scale and then
you have net you have the outer planets
Saturn Uranus Neptune and then if we
have a qui per belt and this is more
asteroids but these are kind of more
frozen you know and when we think of ice
you always think of water ice but out
here it's so cold and it's it's
relatively getting dark now because
we're pretty far from the Sun that
things that we normally associate as
gases are going to be in their solid
form out here so this isn't just rocky
elements this will also be things that
we normally associate as gases like
methane
frozen methane but even here we're not
done we're not even out of the solar
system yet we're not even out of the
solar system yet and actually just to
give you a sense just to give you a
sense of the scale we're operating right
here I have this chart right here
from the Voyager mission so the Voyager
missions Voyager 1 and 2 actually
Voyager 2 left a little bit earlier a
month earlier the Voyager 1 is just
traveling faster they left about a year
after I was born a year after I was born
and their current velocity just to give
you a sense of how fast how fast Voyager
1 right here Voyager 1 right here is
right now traveling at 60 1060 1,000
kilometers per hour that's about 17
kilometers per second the size of a city
every second it's going that fast that's
at least in my mind and unfathomably
fast velocity this thing has been
traveling roughly that fast you know
it's been going around planets and
getting and gaining acceleration as it
went around orbits but for the most of
the time it's been going at a pretty
fast speed and just to translate it to
people who don't relate to kilometers
that's about 38,000 38,000 miles per
hour so this huge huge unfathomably fast
speed and it's been doing it since 1977
I was I was learning to walk and and and
when I was learning to walk it was
traveling at this super fast speed and
then when I was learning to Ty mean you
know our whole lives when we're sleeping
everything we're eating at Yamin
elementary school is still true akka
ting out of the out of the solar system
at roughly the speed it's velocities
change but especially once it got
outside of the planets it's been roughly
at this at this velocity so it's just
been rocketing out and I don't want to
say only but it's gotten this far it's
gotten this far it's gotten about if we
look at on this scale it's gotten about
that far right there it's about 115 116
astronomical unit and to give a sense so
there's two ways to think about it once
is like wow that's really far because if
we know that even on this scale you
can't even see Earth's orbit so this
looks like it's a pretty pretty far
distance and just to give you a sense of
how far 116 astronomical units are if if
two thousand years ago Jesus got on a
plane
we cut and pasted a copy of Jesus just
for visualization purposes but if he got
on a jetliner at a thousand km/h and
went straight in that direction in the
direction that voyager voyager would
only just now be catching up to Jesus so
this is a huge huge huge huge distance
but at the same time even though it's a
huge distance especially relative to
everything else we've talked about
relative to just even the outer reaches
of the solar system we're still talking
in terms of a small scale so that is
that's how far voyager is and just to
give a sense on this scale so this whole
box over here this whole box over here
can be contained in this box and when
you look at this box voyagers all only
gotten about voyagers only gotten about
that far after traveling at this
unbelievable velocity for over thirty
years for 3334 about thirty three years
and just should give you an idea of
these other things Sedna right here is
one of the it's it's a it's a reasonably
large sized outer solar system object
it's it's it's one of the farthest
objects that we know of in the solar
system and it has this very eccentric
orbit so it gets I don't want to say
relatively close but not unreasonably
far away and then it gets really far
away from from the app from the Sun but
even Sedna's orbit so if I were to look
at this so this whole box over here this
whole box over here can be contained
right over here so in this diagram right
here you couldn't even you wouldn't even
be able to see it would be like a speck
how far voyager has traveled in 33 years
at 38,000 miles per hour you would not
even be able to notice you wouldn't even
notice that distance and even though you
can't even notice that distance we still
have the sun's influence the
gravitational is still at the
gravitational pull is still attracting
things to it and this right here this
right here we speculate that there's the
Oort cloud and this is where the Comets
originate from this is just a bunch of
frozen you can almost fit you know
frozen gases and ice particles and
things like that but this is kind of
we're starting to get to the outer
reaches of the solar system in this
distance right here this distance right
here is about 50,000 50,000 astronomical
units
50,000 astronomical units and just to
give a scale because you hear a lot
about light years and all of that light
years are about 63,000 astronomical
units so if you go a light year out from
the cloud you will light you're out from
the Sun you'll end up in in the Oort
cloud the the hypothesized Oort cloud
and just to give a sense another scale
the Oort cloud is actually you know most
of the planets orbits are roughly in the
same plane but this right here is the
the orbit of the planets and once again
these lines are drawn too thick they're
just drawn the thin as possible so that
you can see them but they're still drawn
too thick and this goes gets us all the
way to the creeper belt but all of this
over here it's all the way out to the
creeper belt all the way out to all of
the major planets this is pollute this
is Pluto's orbit right over here this is
Pluto's orbit right over here this whole
diagram is only sitting in right over
there you can barely see it that's this
whole diagram is just that dot in this
and then you can see the Oort cloud all
around it it's more of a spherical cloud
and we think it exists obviously you
it's hard to observe things at that
distance so hopefully that gives you a
gaming sense of the scale of the solar
system and what's really going to blow
your mind if this hasn't blown your mind
already is that this whole thing is
going to start looking like a speck when
you even just look at the local area
around of our galaxy and then much less
the galaxy as a whole much less the
universe as a whole
anyway I don't want to get well anyway
there's this this is this is starting to
get crazy